Pretty sure you know at this point I'm a small
government guy.
What small government means to me economically,
is you should keep most of what you earn,
and you yourself are the best arbiter to decide
where you money goes.
Whether the money goes to fixing your house
or buying a new car or to funding Planned
Parenthood or supporting Lincoln Center, it's
up to you.
You've worked hard for your money and I believe
you are a better judge of how to spend it
rather than giving it to a wasteful government,
who will often spend it on programs you don't
even care about.
At the same time, being for small government
isn't only about taxes and economics.
At its root, being for small governement is
also being for the individual.
I believe your faculty to understand how you
want to live, is far better than anyone else
telling you how to live your life.
At the same time, I understand the need for
the government is different if you live in
a rural area or in an urban center.
In a rural area with less people, there is
most likely a lesser need for regulation than
there is in an urban area.
Take something as simple as noise ordinances.
If you live in a remote rural area, there
is most likely no need for a law to stop people
from doing construction at night or blasting
music too loudly.
But if you live in an urban center, say New
York City, where people live in small apartments
on top of one another, a noise ordinance might
be important.
You can't have construction people knocking
down walls at all hours of the night, and
you might not want your neighbor blasting
music at 3 am.
The next piece of the limited government puzzle
puzzle is does the government have to be involved
so many facets of our life at all?
Even in the case of New York City with it's
cramped conditions and tiny living spaces,
is it the government who has to tell companies
not to do construction or tenants not to blast
music?
This is where an interesting discussion can
happen.
Is it the job of the government, as laid out
by the constitution to regulate these interpersonal
issues?
Or is it the job of individuals to deal with
these issues themselves?
Should a building in NYC have a policy about
noise, instead of leaving it to the government?
Should it be incumbent on you to talk to your
neighbor about the volume of their music,
rather than leaving it to the government?
Can issues we think of traditionally being
dealt with by the government actually be dealt
with in the private sector?
Is the government already to deep into controlling
us that we could never scale it back without
burning down the system?
While noise ordinances aren't the most pressing
issue out there, I use it as a simple example
of the battle between the private and the
public and how sometimes we assign power to
the government when perhaps there could be
a better option based in our own capacity
to reason for ourselves.
With all this in mind, we're continuing our
partnership with Learn Liberty this week and
joining me is best selling author and economist
at George Mason University, Bryan Caplan.
Bryan is an anarcho-capitalist, which is in
simple terms is an extreme libertarian who
wants government pretty much out of everything.
We'll talk about taxes, healthcare, rent control
and much more and see if there are places
that private can do a better job than what
the public has been able to do.
Now according to US Penal Code 429 pursuant
to the laws of the state you are in you are
hereby ordered to click like and comment down
below.